Professor I can just tell you that we
have information that Donald Trump has
now been formally arrested and he is uh
um that has just happened and he said on
his way there he said heading to lower
Manhattan the courthouse seems so
surreal wow they're going to arrest me
well they now have and so
um Professor do you think this is we've
heard a lot of different arguments uh in
the last hour or two do you think it is
damaging for Donald Trump or will he
benefit politically from it well you've
got to make a distinction here he may in
the short run politically benefit in a
Republican primary and look Ron DeSantis
Mike Pence and with the exception of
Asia ASA Hutchinson all of his Rivals
have sniveled at his feet and adopted
the same Bluster as Donald Trump not
giving Republican voters any reason to
vote for them as opposed for Trump but
it's a very different matter when it
comes to a general election 60 percent
according to a recent CNN poll support
the indictment 70 percent think that
Donald Trump did something minimally
unethical and arguably illegal he also
faces a very serious possible criminal
indictments in Georgia for tampering
with a free and fair election in the doj
for possibly inciting an Insurrection
and mishandling National Security
documents I don't think he can survive
even in the Republican primary if he
gets all of these indictments